one of the things that seems to me that
it's so important is about about story
and that's the thing that this is all
about for me and not just somebody
telling you something but the fact that
you carry it you fold your own life any
of your own culture and carry it is so
important to me and that's what I wanted
to do I wanted to make those kind of
films so I but it need to need a life to
be able to do that so it just happens
just about now I'm just my wife Lily
thank god she's here taking care of me
but anyway I was the bad I was just
about to say she doesn't know this but
just about 75 years ago because I was
only 15 when I got asked after graduated
of high school and they asked me to
write to tell some story and because i
was you know they get good a graduate
and I love you guys I didn't tell
anybody these stories but this is the
truth and and so I was mostly my head
was full of things like Moby Dick and
Conrad and people like that that's what
carried in me in my head that's the way
I learned about things but in the books
and then I decided that sometime I had
to be out in the world and lived so
anyway I was asked to mike's debris get
to talk to this beep of this group of
this was at the cadet he graduating and
so i had to speak to them and i'll never
forget it in my life because this was 75
years ago i walked out to the center the
of this place right like this pick up
this thing and i looked at everybody I
couldn't say anything
and then right there was beginning
giggle and then a little bit later it
was laughter and then finally I just
left and that was at least a minute that
I was standing there because I had
nothing to say so that's what I that's
why I realized that the people who don't
have a chance to speak those are people
who don't hear them I wanted I wanted to
make those kind of films well that's why
I lived with other people so I'm lucky
so I know I'm going on and on but last
thing I just wanted to mention the last
thing and i'll get finished is there was
an so i wanted to live with that people
who were so eloquent and who had
something to say and catch capture their
own their own culture and I remember I
was watching and it in the south because
i went to the south because i thought
what was happening in this country was
very important to be in segregation and
things like that and i wanted to live
with those people and I lived with the
people with a man I don't remember his
name name but he was plowing with his
mules you know and and he stood next and
I'm talking him and he said to me he
said that Lincoln lived over oft slavery
from the yoke but we left us with the
bowl so here are my god this is lucky a
person to be able to be talking like
like Melville really you know that I
could this a person that ordinary people
and this guy telling me that Lincoln
lifteth or the the yoke and that's the
yolk that you carry the two mules and
the bowl is the wood of the bowl that
makes the so you can carry it and then
behind it of course is the plow and and
that is what I to me this is all about
and that this is
that making the sea stories is about the
plow plow because the ground you have to
break down all of the things that has
created on and on the crust and you have
to attack that steel both of the of the
cut through the but the ground and open
it so that all the breakthrough that the
things that everybody thinks that they
really are and it breaks them up so that
you can tell stories and the different
the good things of the bad things and
all of these kind of things so you could
understand who you really are anyway so
I'm finished thank you very much